hello everyone this is Matthew and today
we're going to introduce you to what
DevOps K is we're gonna cover a few key
elements we're going to take you through
how DevOps came into being what DevOps K
is you'll also look at the stages and
the tools that are used to implement
DevOps and dev are practices within your
organization I'll take a look at and
introduce what Etsy is doing with DevOps
and how it transformed how they were
able to be successful and finally we'll
tie everything up by going through the
benefits of what DevOps is so let's jump
into the first stage here of how DevOps
came into being to do this i'm going to
tell a little bit of a story and we're
gonna use this story to help explain how
different types of delivering models are
used to implement different ways of
pushing software and services into the
world and there are three main types as
waterful agile and then we'll get into
DevOps
so here we have Max and Max is actually
studying at school and the story that
we're gonna tell here is how max learned
different ways of being able to delight
her customer now the first way that Max
learned how to delight her customer so
what max is looking to do is to complete
her assignment at the end of the year
and she's doing this because her
instructor has given her a final exam
and she has to be successful in that
final exam so what is her exam so she
has to be able to produce 200 dresses
that meet and delight her customer now
the first approach max is going to take
is just going to take the waterfall
model and the waterfall model approach
is one where we have different groups of
people separated from each other so we
have max who is a designer who is going
to design the outfit and then max is
then gonna give that outfit to a tailor
and then the tailor is then going to
create 200 dresses at the end of which
it's going to be handed over to the
teacher but here's the problem with the
waterfall model is that you have a
cascading delivery approach where one
group hands off to our next group that
hands off to a next group but finally
when the
nitin is given to the group that
actually wants the product in this case
the teacher what we find out is that
because we haven't worked with the
teacher all the work that we've been
doing has been wrong this is one of the
reasons why that you see such
significant failure rates within IT is
that we are delivering solutions and
taking so much time but we're not gonna
impact from the people who are providing
us the guidance so this is waterfall
model so let's kind of like look at some
of these elements so how water forms
came into being is that we have key
elements such as requirements that are
given by a group in this case the
teacher but it could be a business team
that you're working with we have the
designer who could be the developers and
the engineers creating and then we have
people who have been scaling the work
that we're doing at high levels this is
seen as the implementation team but this
could also be your software factory team
that's working offshore and then finally
you want to get back and get
verification from the people who provide
you the crimes in the first place that
you've delivered what they needed and
after all this we go into a maintenance
phase so you know as there are changes
that happen you have to do maintenance
so let's look at the next stage here
which is agile and the difference
between agile and waterfall is that you
can kind of almost see that instead of
taking three months to do a delivery
with agile we're taking two weeks to do
delivery there are what's called sprints
and agile which are bi-weekly cadence of
delivering now some companies have
Sprint's are only one week long some
have four weeks long typically you have
two weeks so in this instance the
designer creates a dress hands it to the
tailor and then instead of the tailor
then creating two hundred dresses here
just creates one and hands it to the
teacher for review well you know what
the teacher then can give immediate
feedback and then we go through the
process again for another two weeks and
we get to the end of that two weeks and
you know what in this instance we've now
created the dress that the teacher wants
from the requirements that have been
handed out what's awesome about this
instead of taking three months to create
an additional hundred ninety-nine
dresses we've only created one dress
that was not correct and then the rest
of the dresses are now created correctly
and we can start accelerating our
delivery cycles but there's a problem
we're missing out a critical element in
this model and that person is the
customer and the customer experience is
what's driving devops because the
teacher or the person with the
requirements may believe that they know
what the customer wants but until the
customer actually tries on the product
they're not going to have that
real-world feedback and so in this
instance we've created a product that
just doesn't fit the customer and
something has to be done about that so
this is where we start looking at ways
in which death ops can be optimized to
the customer so here is the approach
that we have for an agile we have the
requirements we have the desire these
don't change we have the development
team and who are creating the product
but here is the key element that does
change we have testing and feedback we
have these as continuous loops that take
the information that we got initially as
our requirements document and we test
those with our customers actually out in
the field and this becomes a continuous
loop that is providing data back into
our team and we're using data and
testing to validate the product moving
forward so the goal for DevOps
is to have disparate teams working
together so you need to break down those
silos you have within your
organization's and have the teams and
connect it and when they do they're able
to improve upon each other's skills so
when we get feedback from the customer
that a shirt may fit too loosely we can
then incorporate that and feedback right
back into our delivery loop until we're
able to with just a few stitches adjust
that shirt in real time and you're
seeing this today with a lot of large
websites such as Google office 365 and
then later will step in and
and see where those sites and those
applications those web applications are
being updated in almost real-time and
this is the DevOps approach so the
deadlines team is there for creating the
product but they're there in alignment
with the operations team who's
responsible for deploying them the pro
the two instead of being disparate teams
working away from each other are closely
connected and the key to this is that
testing element we will talk a little
bit more about how these DevOps teams
using testing and automation are able to
increase and improve the efficiency of
the product that's released so DevOps is
a software engineering culture and
history is from the world of development
operations instead of them being
separated pulling the two together so
let's talk a little bit about the stages
and tools that are within DevOps
you will see at the centre of our
diagram here but integration is key for
all the work we do so typically with
development you have planning coding
building and then testing and then
within operations you have deployment
operations and monitoring with DevOps is
how can we provide the tools that allow
these two worlds to coexist with each
other so if we're looking at planning
and coding going to be using the tools
that allow us to be able to manage our
work that needs to be done and going
through an pipeline process and code
versioning we want to be able to have
the tools that to automatically collect
the code that's been created and
automatically build those applications
and you'll see that the term automatic
is something that is a consistent with
DevOps testing also becomes automated so
everything that gets created every time
code is checked into your git repository
you will be able to test that code and
you're doing the testing so instead of
getting to the end of a project and
having a face such as regression testing
where you're trying to find all the
things that are not working by having
continuous testing on every single
aspect of every piece of code that you
write you're able to create a library of
code that has a complete and
complimentary library of testing
so it doesn't matter if you enter in a
new code block yep that code book will
be tested against all the other existing
test cases that you have and then you're
looking at the tools and we have here a
couple examples of puppet and shad which
are deployment tools that when you push
out your code instead of having maybe
the different versions of code delivery
you have where your build environment
stage and deployment environment may be
different because it's difficult to have
those aligned these tools in a DevOps
environment are in assuring that each of
those environments are completely
identical and that when you push out the
code to the production environment that
you're creating identical environments
for the rest of the development and
coding to be created and there isn't the
issue of while this runs on my computer
but not on your computer everything is
consistent and then the final stage is
we want to train and this is really
critical you want to be able to monitor
the complete performance of all the work
that you're doing really every single
aspect because there are so many
variances on the way in which your
consumers can connect with you from
mobile devices from desktop devices and
now the emerging technologies such as
voice and augmented reality we're seeing
just a huge number of ways of which
consumers can connect with the digital
message that you're sending and then the
heart of DevOps is integration for all
of these tools and we've provided
example tools through these slides here
but there is a much bigger and deeper
collection of tools that you can also
work with but these are some of the most
popular ones so let's talk a little bit
about the implementation of DevOps so
the previous slide we talked about
integration particularly with Jenkins
being the center of the universe for
everything you're doing and what you'll
see as we go through the next couple of
slides is that it doesn't matter what
you're doing as you move through the
different implementation stages of
divorce what you'll find is every steps
through that integration point so what
that means is that instead of having a
clear different gates that you may be
building and deploying your solutions on
what you actually do
is building and coding deploying testing
and monitoring simultaneously all the
time using your integration point as a
way to be able to control how the code
is being delivered so you can be
fetching and building code integration
points of them the way in which you do
that you can be testing your code you
can be doing automatic deployment if all
the right tests are approved and the the
work that's being done within your
deployment tours has been approved then
you automatically deploy you're able to
then monitor and get information back
into your integration point which then
sends back the work that needs to be
done in the planning stages are creating
your backlog and then the next round of
code that has to be created there
becomes this virtuous cycle that feeds
itself
so within DevOps we're looking at a
number of key things we want to automate
and have continuous integration it's not
an event that happens within your
program it is something that is
continuously executed on the same thing
boom is for delivery delivery doesn't
become an event what you're doing with
DevOps is you're continuously delivery
and that delivery is dependent on the
code you write meeting the test you've
written for your integration so
everything that is being tested as soon
as it passes that test you deploy out to
your production environment so how do
you manage the deployment you know
before we have worked in very large
programs that took a significant amount
of communication and effort to deploy
with DevOps we go in two completely
opposite direction we're looking at
creating lots and lots of small
implementations I'll give you an example
on any given day office 365 and we all
use office 365 on a daily basis goes
through hundreds of small independent
updates that are built on micro services
the other advantage you have when you
start building elements that are micro
Services is that you can connect to
those micro services to build out
additional features and functionality at
a faster rate later a good example of
this is the way in which Amazon
built out and scaled up there AWS
environment from a few number of
services in 2008 to thousands of
services today they're able to do that
because they have implemented micro
services as a way to scale up rapidly
monitoring and logging all aspects of
the application you want to become
obsessive about the performers of your
solution and don't look at the
performance of your solution through a
single lens keep the direction that
you're working on as a way to be able to
delight your customer so that means
building out a website that works and is
optimized for mobile also ensuring that
that website works for desktop there's
still a lot of people building out
websites just for desktop 80% of your
traffic is going to be mobile traffic
today also bear in mind that the API is
into those applications have to be
monitored and that the people connecting
to your content will be doing it through
multiple different networks some of
those people will be sitting at home at
their desktop and they'll have a high
speed internet connection other people
will be walking down the street and
using their phone and they'll have a
slower wireless interconnection another
key point that's different with DevOps
with traditional environments is that
you want to look at your core
infrastructure as code what that means
is that you want to look at the
environment that you're creating your
solution for so five years ago if you
were building out a solution you would
have physical hardware and you would
install windows onto those servers or
Linux into those servers and you'd have
to build out a series of programs that
would run on those servers the next
evolution was virtualization and that
has continued to evolve until where we
are today is containers and containers
are a way in which you can actually
script out using technologies like uber
Nettie's to be able to create the
operations infrastructure in just code
and execute it against code the
advantage that you have by doing that is
that you can write in code what the
environment should look like water all
the piece of software on what is the
version and then if something changes
where
you need to be able to test that and
have your developers working that same
environment you can actually just give
them the code for the container of what
that would look like and they can
immediately have the same exact
environment running so they can be
testing and there is no doubt then that
the code that they are creating will
work exactly the same in the production
brand as is within their development
environment and then communication
becomes just an incredible tool when
you're working with DevOps because
you're looking at doing multiple
releases continuously throughout the day
and pushing those releases to all of
your customers to help continue
delighting your customers and what you
can see with the communication point
point is you want to take advantage of
tools such as slack or Microsoft teams
where you're able to take all the
different tools that we've been talking
about such as Jenkins such as get such
as Shem and have those tools can talk to
your communication tools which is the
tools that your team uses to share
information and broadcast to those teams
when successful updates have been pushed
out and the team as a whole knows in
real time all of the changes that are
happening so let's use an example here
of Etsy and where they were able to be
successful so Etsy is a very successful
e-commerce site and if you are into
crafting then you probably have already
used Etsy you may have even sold
features on Etsy but the challenge that
Etsy had is that then when they were
working in an agile point of view they
were running into problems for when they
would gain rate to release products into
the real world it would take them up to
four hours to update the Etsy website
and when you're updating the website
twice a week and you're down for four
hours each time each of those seconds
that you're down you are losing people
to another website and you're losing
revenue and this just really kind of
drove down the number of potential
customers that could be buying from Etsy
and so what they realize is that the
updates had to happen both a faster to
me
constant changes in needs of the
consumer but then the website itself
could not come down and to do this Etsy
created a tool called the deploy inator
and I just love that name just so the
deploy inator is the tool that is used
to continuously deploy code from Etsy
and what's great about the deploy nater
is that it's open-source you can had to
go ahead and download and see the talk
that Etsy is actually using the tall
allowed it for the automation of
deployment and what that led to was just
this continuous release of updates and
Etsy today has over 50 updates every
single day I think about that Etsy is
updating their website every 26 minutes
so what are the benefits of going
through DevOps versus agile and
waterfall and the first and I think
really the biggest benefit is that you
are constantly testing and delivering on
technology in a continuous pattern you
are not waiting for somebody to approve
a release and then having a release
happen you're using the testing and the
analytics to be able to validate that
what you've created or work the second
is that you're breaking everything down
into the smallest tiniest chunk to be
able to validate that chunk will work in
that environment and then you're looking
at automating the whole of this
environment and that automation helps
you reinforce and validate security and
it also allows you to provide a self
audit track to be able to validate the
changes that you've made so hopefully
you've learned something from this video
here are some key takeaways that like
you to have and the first one is that
what full agile and DevOps are really
ways of which delivery has matured
within IT organization and businesses as
a whole but DevOps is a way to be able
to maximize the way to continuously
delight your customer and DevOps is that
wonderful space where both development
and operations come together and the way
that it comes together is through the
use of tools and tools our sin
for all the work you're doing
particularly integration tools and being
able to automate and test all of the
code that you're working through but
there are some best practices that help
you define how your DevOps team will
work and execute and finally we use Etsy
as an example of instead of having their
website down for four hours at a time
for when they would make an update and
having to do that twice a week now the
website is not down at all so they
gained an additional four hours every
updates in e-commerce and on top of that
Etsy is now releasing over 50 updates
every single day so I want to thank you
and hopefully you've learned something
from this class if you want to learn
more click like for the subscribe or
this YouTube channel and also join us at
simply learn dot-com hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simply
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos Dinard up and get
certified
click here